Roxy: Eggsy!
Eggsy: Yours first, OK?
Roxy: Yep.
Being able to grip and hold on
is virtually impossible.
That parachute is designed for one person.
Hi, I'm Mike Elliott, a
26-year combat veteran.
I served 11 years with the US Army
Golden Knight Parachute Team.
I have over 16,000 skydives,
6,000 tandems, 100 static-line jumps,
and about 20 military free-fall jumps.
Today we're going to be
looking at parachuting scenes
in movies and judge how real they are.
Oh, come on, come on, come on, come on.
I think he did the correct procedures.
With military free-fall
jumpers with combat equipment,
they have their O2 masks on, googles,
it's a lot of moving parts,
so there is a possibility that
something could come loose.
He takes about 15 seconds
to fix his O2 pipe and
put it back to his helmet.
You can hold your breath up
to a minute and still be OK,
so he had plenty of time to fix his mask
and still leave the aircraft.
His bottom position is very correct here.
He's in what we call a dive position.
And it is so über-important
to have the correct body position.
Basically, you have to learn
how to push air with your body
so the wind is basically
hitting him around his waist
and chest area, which allows that wind
to be symmetrical around his body
so he can gain stability
after he exits the aircraft.
Automated voice: 25,000 feet.
They did a very great
job as a HALO jumper.
Basically, HALO is "high
altitude, low opening,"
meaning you exit the
aircraft above 15,000 feet.
You have to have some type
of breathing apparatus
in the aircraft as well as on your body.
As far as the form is concerned,
there's no different form with HALO.
It's called the box-man
position or the arch position.
Everything he's doing in
this scene is done correctly.
Your knees are bent, your
pelvis is pushed forward,
your arms are back.
That is a pretty gnarly-looking storm.
I have never had to jump
into clouds and lightning,
and it's not even approved
by the Federal Aviation Administration.
With clouds, you cannot see the ground
and you can get struck by lightning.
And if you're flying with other jumpers,
now you at a risk of
running into another person.
And when you slam into another
person at 120 miles per hour,
it's going to be some serious injuries.
Automated voice: 4,000.
Deploy. Deploy. Deploy.
I do like that the body position
of both actors in this movie are correct.
If you're unconscious, you're
going to be on your back,
because your arms and legs
are the lowest portions
of your body, so gravity
will put you on your back.
I would rate this a high 7, for sure.
All those are very unique maneuvers
that could possibly happen.
[Mike laughing]
Well, very unrealistic scene.
There is no way anyone
could have made it through
that type of debris.
To bring it more home,
I was at an altitude
of about 14,000 feet, and
we had some icing conditions
when we stepped out of the airplane.
And it was the most painful thing
that I think I've ever experienced.
It was like being shot in
the face with a BB gun.
So if you can think about
getting hit by a piece of that debris,
there's no way I would've
left that building
with a parachute whatsoever.
You could catch up with
someone in free fall.
With that position she was
in, the full delta position,
you straighten your legs
and you pull your arms against your body,
so there's nothing out
there that's going to
create the wind from
flowing around your body.
You can get up to 250 to
280 miles an hour, easy.
I'm not going to say this
particular episode was realistic.
For every action, there's
a reaction in free fall.
If you're looking up
trying to find someone,
that is going to change
your whole body position.
I mean, it's going to change the airflow
of symmetry around your body,
so you're going to slow down
and you're going to come out of that dive.
I don't know of anyone that has
put a parachute on in midair.
In order to put those leg
straps around your legs,
put your arms in that
harness at 120 miles an hour
with debris falling around you,
I don't believe that is possible.
I would say 1.
Nothing in this clip, to
me, looks real whatsoever.
[beeping]
A total high five on this scene,
from the ramp to the exit.
With a military free-fall operation,
each group that's exiting an
aircraft has a team leader.
And you're guiding all the guys,
so they are grouping around him
so they can see what's going on.
And that's the same formation they stay in
during their exit and as
they get out into free fall.
As you see here, they
jumping at nighttime.
Everything gets really,
really difficult at nighttime
because you're either flying through NODs
or just with your naked eye,
and you can't see obstacles.
You can't see the ground coming up.
And in the Army, you have
the round static-line jumps
from, like, the 82nd Airborne Division,
and you have the Army Parachute Team,
which are demonstrations
and competitive-type guys.
On the special-operations
side, the US Navy SEALs
or Delta Force or Special
Forces, these guys are trained
to put that parachute
where they need to put it
to do what they need to do best.
So if these guys are illustrating
from a spec-ops side,
yes, that is something that
can definitely be done.
In this particular scene,
they're doing a HALO.
Special-operations soldiers,
their thing is to be
as stealthy and as quiet
and as dark as they can.
And the premise of a HALO
jump is soldiers can step out
up to 40 or 50 miles away at 25,000 feet,
open their parachute by 20,000 feet,
and they can drift in quietly,
stealthily, undetected
from miles away.
For this, I don't know
why they would have smoke.
Especially how you can't
see smoke at nighttime.
It's mandatory to have
blinking lights on your body
when you're flying at nighttime,
so other aircraft can see you.
Special-operation guys,
they're not going to have
any lights and flares
because they're coming in as stealthily,
as quiet as possible,
so they can do the mission
once they get on the ground.
The landing, as you see,
it's a extremely tight area.
The tight parachutes that are
military, special-op guys,
it's called MC-4s, MC-5s.
Very big, very docile parachutes.
They definitely can land on
buildings and tight areas.
I don't think they would
land in something that tight.
Not a bad-looking clip at all.
Yeah, I would give them a 6.
But I don't know how to parachute.
That's OK, we're going to tandem jump.
Trust me.
First of all, when was that moment
that you put a tandem parachute
and a tandem harness
inside of the airplane?
Yeah, I was the team leader
for the tandem team on the
US Army Parachute Team.
And I was selected to jump
with our former President Bush.
In order to do a tandem jump,
it takes a good 15 to 20
minutes to don that harness
as well as his parachute system.
I mean, you have to watch a waiver video
and go through the procedures,
because a licensed,
experienced tandem instructor
could take a person with no experience,
and he can go through the
thrills of free-falling.
They just didn't have
enough time to prepare
for a tandem operation while in flight.
Ready?
Do I sound ready?
Yep.
[Emma screaming]
That is a correct exit,
to use a seated position
to leap from the aircraft.
Normally if you're
doing a seated position,
you have someone that's
really nervous of the jump
or a little heavier,
so a seated position's the best way
to get them out of the door
into the relative wind.
[Emma screaming]
If you notice, there's a
cord coming out of the back
of Dwayne Johnson's parachute.
That is called a drogue.
Because of the speed of
two people together --
normal speed of one person in free fall
is about 120 miles an hour.
Well, for a tandem, that speed increases
to about 180 miles an hour.
So you have to set that drogue out,
which is basically a
smaller round parachute
to slow you back down
to 120 miles an hour.
You see him here tapping her.
That tap is for her to bring
her arms back into her body,
because he's getting ready
to open up the parachute.
You don't want the
passenger to grab handles
during that opening process.
Because you have two
folks under one canopy,
the canopy is a lot bigger,
so things have to open a lot higher.
A normal tandem opening
procedure starts at 5,500 feet.
If you're doing a solo jump,
you can take it down as low as 2,500 feet.
And if you noticed in the clip,
the drogue kind of collapses
and the parachute comes out,
very proper opening technique.
I'm going to rate this about a 4,
simply because the training technique
inside of the aircraft.
Wow. I mean, every time I
see a static-line operation
at this depth, it gives me chill bumps
to think about soldiers in World War II.
The forefathers of parachuting.
With static-line jumping,
it's the most expedient way
to put soldiers on the battlefield.
If you look at some of the actual footage
that happened on D-Day
and Market Garden, that's
basically what you see.
Numerous, numerous parachutes
in the air at any given time.
So, this is absolutely 100% correct.
I was actually an airborne
instructor for three years,
where I trained parachutists
how to become paratroopers.
And the best way to get out
the aircraft is basically
you pushing the guy in
front of you out the door
so you can get out the
door as quick as possible.
And as you exit, you get into
a good, tight body position,
which is your hands over your harness,
feet and knees together.
And that static line actually
pulls your parachute out,
and your parachute opens automatically.
I'm going to rate this as a 10.
Just amazing any and every time I see
what the guys done for
us back in World War II.
There are so many different facets
of maneuvering your body through the air.
It's called free-flying.
You can fly on your feet,
you can fly on your head,
you can fly in a ball,
and it's all about learning
how to maneuver air
with your body in whatever
position you're in.
So yes, this is very, very
accurate, what he's doing.
F---! Whoa!
If we can stop here for a second.
They are portraying that
you can talk in the air.
At 120 miles an hour,
falling 176 feet per second,
you cannot hear anything but
the air rushing past your ears.
[Johnny laughing]
Wow, what a long free fall.
So, I don't know what altitude
they exited the aircraft from,
but obviously it was
not above 15,000 feet,
because they don't have O2 masks on.
At 12,000 feet, you're looking at
about 45 seconds of free-fall time.
So, here we are, still falling.
So, wow, they must've got
up really, really high.
You're a speed star!
A lot of this happens
on the Golden Knights.
The Golden Knights have a
free-fall-formation team,
a eight-way team that go out
and do these geometrical formations.
This formation we're looking
at is called a star formation,
and what they're doing is very correct.
As you see, he's kind of
coming in nice and slow.
You have to slow your
body down to approach that
to make sure you don't
take that formation out.
When you see the guys that are
grabbing each other's wrists,
that is called taking a dock
on the person to your
left or to your right.
In order to consider it
being a built formation,
you have to hold on to another person,
either by their jumpsuit
or by their wrist or by their arms.
And then for them to
have inexperienced jumper
and make it to a formation
with no problems,
that's never gonna happen.
The average person that can
build a formation this size
probably has about 100 jumps.
When you're watching a movie that it shows
a guy just putting on a parachute
and jumping out of an airplane,
that is nowhere near close
to absolutely happening.
That's a lot of time, a lot of training
that goes behind doing
a parachute operation.
So I'm going to say a 5 for this one.
Very realistic of what
kind of canopy he's flying.
He's flying a seven-cell
demonstration parachute
made for pinpoint landing.
And his exit procedure,
his hand when he deploys
the parachute's all correct.
If I bring my hand over my head,
that keeps the air
symmetrical around my body,
so I still gain the stability
during the opening
process of my parachute.
And that's how you enter a party.
[laughing] I love it.
I've jumped into The Pentagon.
Done a lot of pretty unique places.
You have to submit a air request
through the Federal
Aviation Administration.
They are going to be the
ones that approve you
to jump and to land in
these different areas.
So, they are a little close
in this actual landing.
By the FAA and United States
Parachute Association,
you can land no closer
than 15 feet from people,
and you can fly no lower than
15 feet above their heads.
When you see him come
across the folks' heads
and land right in front of them,
you would have a little
more distance to that,
and you would have to have
a marked-off drop zone,
meaning with a safety
officer on the ground
controlling the crowd. Now, if you notice,
he looks like he's just
pinching the controls
with his index finger and his thumb.
I wouldn't advise that,
because there's so much
pressure on those toggles.
Toggles are very, very important.
It's like the brakes on a car.
To keep those toggles secure,
you make a fist around your control.
Or if you're like Golden Knights,
we fly with our hands above
the toggles wrapped into a fist
for a safe, soft, stand-up landing.
As you see him coming in here,
as soon as he pulled down
to stop his parachute,
he would lose his toggles.
What a wonderful day to become a knight.
Yes, you can get out of
your equipment pretty quick.
Basically it's only three
points of connection.
You have the chest strap
and your two leg straps.
So if you have quick releases,
as soon as your feet hit the ground,
you pop your two leg connectors,
you pop your chest strap,
and you let the parachute
fall off your shoulders.
Just a few minute things on his landing,
but everything else,
as long as he had the correct
approvals, looks real good.
So we're going to give him a 8.
Roxy: Eggsy!
Eggsy: Yours first, OK?
Roxy: Yep, OK.
Being able to grip and hold
on is virtually impossible.
That parachute is designed for one person,
and you're not hooked up properly
as if you're doing a tandem.
But if I knew there was a possibility
that parachute could save both our lives,
then I would make that attempt to do that.
I was trying to look and see
what their altimeter reading was.
You know, I couldn't really see.
I see it's flashing "LOW ALTITUDE,"
but we have no idea of how low they are
before they open up their main parachute.
2,500 feet is when you open
up your main parachute.
It takes time for those
things to fully open.
With today's parachute systems,
we have what we call a
automatic opening device.
It's going to open up the
reserve parachute for you,
and that is designed to
open at a low altitude.
So your main parachute, which
they are using in this scene,
they could open up at
that low of an altitude,
is not very realistic.
To have someone attached
to you and land on a target
that's not doing a tandem,
absolutely impossible.
This is called parachute accuracy.
Two people under one parachute,
somebody's going to break
some ankles for sure.
In that case they should've did
what we call a parachute landing fall,
where you hit the balls of
your feet, calves, thighs,
and your buttocks, which is
the softest part of your body.
So trying to land
and roll to those soft sides of your body
is kind of what they did in this scene.
But there's just no way
that you can even see around that person
enough to fly that
parachute to a target area.
I'm going to rate these guys at a 5.
I love the fact that they did highlight
on his parachute not
being hooked up properly.
What we have here is
three-ring release system
on his chest strap.
You see the two conduits hanging
out of his main lift web,
which kind of started
the whole malfunction
that he was sabotaged.
Cut away!
So, he wasted a lot of time
trying to fight this malfunction.
If at any given time
look up and this thing
is not flying properly,
you have to start your cutaway procedures.
Meaning you have two handles:
you have a cutaway handle to
get rid of the bad parachute,
and then you have your secondary handle,
which is going to deploy your auxiliary,
your reserve parachute.
So he's sitting here, he's
playing with this canopy,
and he's losing altitude and time quickly.
Anything lower than 800 or 900 feet,
you stand a chance of it not opening.
So now, by the time he does cut it away,
he's at a lower altitude
to get his reserve out.
And as you can see,
then now his reserve
handle was not working.
When you have a cutaway and
you have to fire your reserve,
there's really not a lot of tension.
So you have the strength to
pull that reserve handle out.
Before I pick up my parachute,
I do a overall inspection
of it each and every time.
That's just safety
procedures in the sport.
So, very unlikely that
you're going to have
a sabotaged parachute nowadays.
Yeah, the guy would've never
made it to his rescuer.
For about every four seconds in free fall,
you lose about 1,000 feet.
So as we watch him go
through his malfunction,
he's probably in free fall
for three or four seconds
trying to get that reserve to open up.
And a guy is going to cut away
from his main open parachute
to come down and try to save him.
There's not enough altitude in the world
for him to do that in
this given situation.
By that time, he would've
impacted the ground, for sure.
I'm going to rate this at a 7.
We know at the bottom end
it got a little dramatic.
My favorite parachuting scene
is in "The Longest Day."
If you ever go to France, you
can see that particular church
that still has a parachute hung up.
I truly love all of
the World War II movies
that show what our
soldiers were up against
during that time frame.
Thanks for watching!
If you enjoyed this video, why
not click on the video above?